Олександра Устінова народна депутатка
України одна з лідерів опозиції Також
вона є членом правління організації
центр протидії корупції ми зустрілися
тут у Вашингтоні Олександру Дякую що
знайшли для нас час Дякую і вам
ви тут у Вашингтоні аби говорити про
необхідність надання Україні літаків f16
чому Вони настільки важливі чому
американський уряд досі вагається І чому
це має таке велике значення для вас
ми просимо винищувачі f16 тому що вони є
частиною системи протиповітряної оборони
на жаль нині ми бачимо як російські
літаки піднімаються в повітря Практично
на українському кордоні І запускають
ракети на нашу територію
їхні можливості набагато більші тому що
вони мають новіші літаки українські
радари мають видимість на 60 кілометрів
а росіяни на 400 ми можемо стріляти на
30 кілометрів а вони більш ніж на 200 км
на жаль Якщо у нас не буде нових
винищувачів нам буде складно навіть
захистити цивільне населення а також
військових з повітря
наші винищувачі збивають дрони шахед і
ракети
але з 50-річним літаком майже з часів
Другої Світової дуже складно працювати
Бо будь-яке протистояння з російськими
літаками це самогубство для наших
пілотів які вже є героями
Ми вже давно просимо про надання
винищувачів пояснюємо потреби для
оборони але на жаль політичного рішення
не має
ключовим аргументом проти є те що
українці не знають як ними керувати А
навчання займе багато часу
ми вже чули такі ж аргументи проти
надання Україні хаймерсів які виявилися
дуже ефективними на полі бою
в Україні діти ходять у футболках із
хаймерсами тому що знають що це крута
зброя
теж саме нам говорили про системи ППО
патріот українці вже навчилися працювати
з ними
те ж саме говорили що до Танків усе
впирається у політичне рішення ми чуємо
не аргументи а виправдання чому нам не
дають літаки
війна триває більше року більше 400 днів
якби про навчання українських пілотів
заговорили півроку тому ми б уже збивали
російські винищувачі і врятували би
багато життів
чому так важливо отримати згоду США адже
є інші держави готові надати Україні f16
дуже важливо заручитися підтримкою США
адже це їхні літаки жодна держава у
світі не може не лише надати а й продати
Україні f16 Хоча є люди і держави які
хочуть купити їх і передати Україні тому
що США мають надати ліцензію на експорт
чому США вагається що вам кажуть
законотворці на капітолійському пагорбів
офіційна відмовка літака ми складно
керувати знову ж таки ми вже чули це
щодо інших видів зброї з якими нині вже
ефективно працюємо але неофіційне
виправдання вони бояться ескалації Ми
чуємо про ескалацію з лютого 2022 року
[музика]
якщо ми дамо вам хаймерси буде ескалація
якщо ми дамо танки буде ескалація поки
ми бачимо що озброєння дає нам
можливість захищатися і давати відсіч а
не загострювати ситуацію
Путін зайшов так далеко після усіх
звірств після всього що світ побачив
завдяки ЗМІ Я не знаю якою ще може бути
ескалація
американський генерал петреус говорив
мені в інтерв'ю що якщо ви отримаєте f16
і достатню зброї війна може закінчитися
восени або принаймні до кінця року Ви
згодні
це цілковий та правда якщо у нас будуть
а в 16 достатньо зброї і боєприпасів
війна може закінчитися вже влітку про це
головнокомандувач ЗСУ залужний чітко
сказав партнерам Якщо ви дасте нам
достатньо зброї аби витіснити росіян з
наших територій ми можемо бути щитом
Європи і захищати не лише себе а й
Європу але для цього треба винищувачі і
важке озброєння
наскільки шкідливим став витік
документів пентагону
витік для нас був не дуже шкідливим тому
що Лише кілька людей в нашій державі
знають якою є ситуація і коли почнеться
Контрнаступ зокрема це президент України
на жаль цей злив показав що в усьому
світі є проблеми з безпекою Ми
сподіваємося що ці проблеми будуть
вирішені тому що багато людей можуть
постраждати якщо стануться нові витоки
інформації
Чи були ви здивовані таким витоком
ви всі насправді Ні це стається не
вперше не лише стосовно України а й щодо
інших проблем на мою думку якщо ми
живемо в цифрову епоху то розуміємо На
жаль що все що є онлайн може бути в
небезпеці
Тож ви не вважаєте що злита інформація
про плани українського наступу шкодить
ваші військові стратегії
немає точної інформації коли почнеться
наступ що ми будемо робити є загальна
інформація про те що вже зроблено ми зі
свого боку плануємо наступ Лише кілька
людей в Україні знають коли він
почнеться і як він буде виглядати як на
мене Ми в безпеці
Ви також є членом правління центру
протидії корупції хочу поговорити трохи
про звинувачення Володимира Зеленського
у співпраці з Росією Симон герш
наприклад оприлюднив таку статтю чи є в
цьому правда
складно звинуватити президента
Зеленського у будь-якій співпраці з
Росією тому що він протистоять одній з
найбільших держав світу
майже всі західні держави просили його
евакуюватися і виїхати з України бо
залишатися було небезпечно Утім Він
відповів що не поїде із захищатиме свою
державу якщо треба буде зі зброєю в
руках
ми розглядаємо такі звинувачення і так
звані зливи як інструменти російської
пропаганди якою годують людей
на жаль у деяких країнах Вона працює
Люди читають це і сумніваються чи треба
підтримувати Україну зброєю чи грошима
мовляв Щось тут не зрозуміло Утім на мою
думку після більш ніж 400 днів війни ми
довели що такі звинувачення фейкові
Дякую вам Олександр дякую вам